das hier ist das Sonntagsfrühstück für
hobbylose poschiertes Ei mit
selbstgemachter Hollandes oh so muss es
aussehen zunächst einmal reduzieren wir
ein bisschen Weißweinessig mit Schotten
und schwarzem Pfeffer ein parallel
schmelze ich ein ordentlichen Block
Butter jetzt trenne ich zwei Eier und
unser Eigelb gebe ich in eine große
Schüssel durch ein Sieb gebe ich jetzt
die Reduktion dazu dann kann ich das
ganze auch schon verquiren wenn das
schön verbunden ist gebe ich es auch
schon auf mein Wasserbad so rühren wir
jetzt bis die Mischung eindckt aber noch
nicht kocht wenn es sich im Volumen
verdoppelt hat können wir es auch von
der Hitze runternehmen und wir beginnen
langsam unsere Butter rein en so die
restliche Butter kommt und wir sehen wir
haben langsam eine schöne soenkonsistenz
erzielt ein Spritzer Zitrone kommt dran
eine Prise Salz und fertig ist die
Holland jetzt müssen wir nur noch ein Ei
pchieren dafür gebe ich ein bisschen
Essig in kochendes Wasser und sobald es
losgeht machen wir den Herd aus und
erschaffen einen kleinen Strudel und
dann können wir unser Ei auch schon in
die Mitte hineinfallen lassen
getoasteter English Muffin unser
poschiertes Ei jede Menge selbstgemachte
Holland das ist einfach sexy noch etwas
knuspriger Bacon dazu Mamaia